who's ready for an exciting countdown to
2022 i'm actor host comedian michael yo
you may have seen me on america's got
talent oh michael you were so good you
put the tea in talent and hello
everybody i am nikki novak i am a
television host from this is my home los
angeles california where there is also a
lot of talent now we're going to be
counting it down in every time zone in
my beautiful home las vegas we're going
to be watching all the great parties
from the beautiful
the gorgeous
resorts hotel and casino
i thought you were talking about me and
you said beautiful and gorgeous well
never mind you know what's better than
one party michael yo what's that four
parties we are going to be counting down
the new year from four different time
zones we're gonna be kicking it off from
times square and that famous ball drop
we're then going to be going to dallas
and denver with some amazing firework
shows and then finally the fabulous las
vegas where we're going to watch
fireworks from seven hotel room talks
and we haven't even got to the
entertainment yet performing live from
american idol scotty mcqueery you may
know him from his hit song five more
minutes i've already had my 15 minutes
never mind
[Music]
no no no no we don't know please don't
put your leg up blue man group will be
there as well hi this is zoe bowie
coming to you live from
elvis's iconic dressing room here at the
west gate las vegas we are so excited to
spend new year's eve 2022 with all of
you see you then
but we want you to join in on the party
as well we want you when you use that
social media use the hashtag vegas n-y-e
we're gonna be checking out all your
party pics whether we're here with your
crew or your solo doing the selfie thing
like i do a lot yeah check it out
countdown to 2022 is going to be airing
on 14 different stations all owned by
nexstar they're all down the west coast
across the southwest and you can also
stream it on their websites so
please join us as we bring in the new
year we cannot wait to see you we can't
wait we'll see you we'll see ya we're
ready
i'm ready i'm wearing sequins yeah she
is she's already ready